uh it's not pleasant to have earthquakes
but it's fantastic to have star Creeks
now stars are hot caches fears and they
also move up and down and we can use
these uh star Quakes to learn what's
inside the star it's the only way to
know
how to look inside a star and that's
just like like seismologists of the
earth you know they they are the only
happy people uh when the art uh the
Earth is quaking let's say why because
the earthquakes create waves they travel
into this the the planets they bounce
back at the iron core and seismographs
detect it and then we can do all sorts
of fun physics and chemistry of our
planet and we do the same but then for
stars